as she cast her ballot in 2019's
election it looked as if myanmar's
democratic future was assured
fourteen months later aung san tsuchi
may well spend the rest of her life in
detention
the latest round of sentencing amounts
to an extra four years in addition to a
previous sentence of two years
two of the cases in which she was found
guilty were for the illegal possession
of walkie-talkies a charge that some say
is an example of how trumped up the
accusations against her are those
walkie-talkies belong to the
bodyguards provided to her by the
ministry of home affairs and guess who
runs the ministry of home affairs it's a
it's a ranking military officer per the
2008 constitution so you know the
military should be actually charging
itself with malfeasance and bringing in
unlicensed walkie-talkies rather than
the person whose house they happen to
find them in
aung san tsuchi and her party the
national league for democracy have won
every election in myanmar since 2012 by
a substantial margin
if as the military government has
proposed new elections are held she
would be a very difficult opponent to
beat
although her international reputation
was tarnished when she appeared to
defend the actions of myanmar's military
for its crackdown against rohingya
muslims she remains an icon for
democracy at home
but despite her detention for the past
11 months resistance to the military
coup remains strong whether it be
or the president of myanmar or anyone
else of the thousands and thousands who
have been arrested and detained and are
facing trumped up charges
uh enough is enough this is unacceptable
and will not be
accepted by by the international
community
age 76 aung san tsuchi has already spent
decades of her life in detention this
latest sentence and the outstanding
charges she still faces could remove her
from the political stage for the
foreseeable future
but a new generation of protesters has
taken to the streets since the military
coup
their persistence suggests they'll
continue the fight for democracy with or
without her
tony chang al jazeera
well w stodhart is a founder of the
alternative asean network on burma she
says sushi's incarceration will continue
to motivate pro-democracy activists to
rise up against the military
there's been a huge amount of
domestic outrage although most people
did expect that aung sang tsuchi will be
sentenced will be subjected to further
jail sentences but i think what was
shocking was that the junta controlled
court actually imposed these sanctions
barely 48 hours after hunsen's
controversial visit this has made hunsen
the chair of asean and asean itself a
laughingstock we've seen over this whole
weekend and probably all of this week is
the continuing
continuing protest and what people are
doing besides banging pots and pans for
which they've been arrested is also what
we call flash mobs and lightnings what
we call lightning strikes where people
all over the country have actually gone
out on the streets to wave banners and
some places which were being bombed
people were actually having what they
call indoor strike where they actually
held up placards and posted selfies of
themselves holding protest placards in
their homes as they hid from bomb
attacks the struggle will go on there's
been a whole wave of new activism and
new young leaders coming up incredibly
brave and incredibly progressive let's
not forget that uh in the month of
december we saw a blitz against nld
officials more than 20 nld officials
were sentenced to lengthy jail terms so
we do need to understand that shutting
down the nld is not the end of the
movement in fact this movement is
stronger than ever